hi everyone Sal Khan here and welcome to
Middle School physics I have Iman Howard
who manages all of our stem content Iman
why should folks be excited about Middle
School physics
so Middle School physics is like the
only science out there that explains how
things happen and so basically
everything's made of matter me you um
the chair that I'm sitting on and this
course is going to explore how we exist
in the natural world so for example we
talk a little bit about movement and
forces and we learned that everything
everything that we have a collision with
has this equal but opposite Force that's
applied when the Collision happens so
that's why when you give those high
fives and then your hand starts stinging
it's because the same Force you gave
your buddy is the same Force they gave
you back and then we also talk about
force in a way where it doesn't touch
you so like I'm thinking like Star Wars
there's like this Force energy like
gravitational uh there's magnetic energy
there's electric energy and then finally
we get into waves and we talk a little
bit about how waves you know exist
whether it's sound waves or even the
waves in the ocean what do you think's
exciting
oh well that's a dangerous question to
ask me I wanted to be a physicist and I
still aspire to be it because you know
we kind of wake up in this Cosmos and
we're just trying to understand what
where we fit in and physics asks the
most fundamental questions about how the
universe works and so when I first
learned about Newton's laws and Fields
and all the things that you just touched
on it started to give me goosebumps
because I'm like wow we can finally
understand how the universe fits
together and then use that to make
predictions and then think about things
that we don't understand and there is so
much that we don't understand so I think
this is the beginning of a very very
exciting journey in physics
I agree so